certifié disque d'or dans plus de 25
pays plus de 27 millions d'exemplaires à
travers le monde tu me rectifies
en France le morceau était resté quatre
mois d'affilée numéro 1 du parrade on
regarde le clip alors on se fait plaisir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ne connaît pas cette chanson qui n'a
pas dansé là-dessus redis-moi alors
dis-nous tout comment est né cette
chanson alors c'est une histoire un peu
longue je vais essayer de raccourcir
elle est née en 73 en fait c'est une
réaction contre les gens qui
m'entouraient qui vivaient leur vie à
moitié qui faisaient tout à moitié donc
c'était un cri en fait en disant vivez
votre vie allez au bout des choses
faites les choses déplacez-vous allez
voir des gens et donc cette chanson est
née dans d'une manière un peu folkie
c'est une chanson très très tendre très
anime de liberté ça c'est oui et je m'en
suis aperçu à posteriori d'ailleurs en
fait que c'était vraiment un hymne on
m'a dit pendant très longtemps c'est un
pléonasme bon une tribir live en anglais
ça c'est pas incorrect mais c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas d'une langue
du langage parlé qui est d'une ange du
langage poétique et je me suis aperçu
aux États-Unis notamment quand je
faisais la promo là-bas que toutes les
minorités toutes les minorités
réagissaient très fort sur boruto viral
ils étaient tous le point levé en oui
oui on est là on va s'affirmer et tout
et cetera donc c'est j'ai fait de la
philo sans le savoir
beaucoup de minorité effectivement
l'avait adopté mais alors est-ce que tu
avais anticipé c'est un tel succès c'est
ça qui est dingue on peut pas imaginer
non pas vraiment de vivre encore pendant
tant d'années derrière grâce à ça on y
entendra quand même par la racine
à mon avis non j'avais pas anticipé la
chose et ça a été une bien agréable
surprise mais la plus belle surprise en
fait ça a été de passer du tube pour moi
un tube c'est un peu éphémère c'est
quelque chose qui peut qui est fragile
qui peut disparaître du jour au
lendemain c'est un épiphénomène là quand
on passe du tube au standard quand on
fait un standard après on me demande de
temps en temps vous êtes pas frustré
d'avoir fait ça mais non j'ai fait un
standard qui existe encore aujourd'hui
aussi bien c'est vrai il existait il y a
43 ans donc tu regardes pas tu voulais
élever des veaux dans le Périgord
[Musique]
franchement mais ça n'a pas duré trop
longtemps par amour
vous touchez bien sûr
indépendamment du truc de base
c'est c'est là où effectivement un
compositeur peut faire un petit peu de
beurre c'est à dire que là ce sont des
droits voisins et sur les droits voisins
notamment sur les pubs on est très très
bien payé ce sont des contrats consignes
et on demande ce que l'on veut
s'accepter au circuser l'année dernière
j'en ai fait 4 donc en fait deux en
France une en Autriche et une au Mexique
donc effectivement c'est c'est quelque
chose qui voilà qui met du beurre dans
les épinards j'aime bien comme il dit
ça y est on veut se placer qu'elle a
voulu se placer on va revenir vers toi
parce qu'on a des questions d'argent
justement pas pour suivre allez Colonel
Reyel 5 grands épisodes de t'accueillir
alors ils chantaient tous avant que tu
arrives
regardez-moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la tournée alors en 2011 c'est votre
titre c'était celui exactement
[Musique]
français 9e en Belgique d'ailleurs
l'album au rapport s'est écoulé à plus
de 200000 210000 exemplaires en France
le clips celui qui 160 millions de vues
sur Youtube et ça va tu as l'air
tranquille content d'être là alors
comment tu as vécu ce succès du jour au
lendemain parce que c'est violent c'est
fort d'un coup alors je l'ai vécu très
sereinement et très bien puisque je
pense que c'est une chance pour un
artiste de pouvoir avoir un titre qui
touche le public le grand public en
l'occurrence d'autant plus que ça
faisait une dizaine d'années que j'avais
commencé la musique donc j'ai fait pas
mal de petites scènes etc et donc quand
tu te retrouves devant un public qui
connaît le les paroles de tes chansons
c'est un véritable plaisir quoi on te
demande toujours de l'interpréter non
sans doute exactement j'ai la chance de
continuer à me produire tous les
week-ends sur toutes les scènes de
France donc effectivement ça a passé une
génération puisque le titre a plus de 10
ans et effectivement j'ai cette chance
de pouvoir continuer à Inter c'est ça
les succès c'est comme Patrick c'est que
colonel avait bien voulu chanter sa
chanson au prénom de ma fille Maya
chanté enfin j'avais été le roi des
papas ce soir-là donc
c'est gentil en tout cas alors justement
il y a un autre prénom féminin qui avait
posé problème c'était Aurélie là tu as
eu des soucis avec ça des soucis oui et
non après le succès il a il a très bien
fonctionné après je pense il a cartonné
c'était un été 2011 sorti le titre que
tout le monde connaît là Aurélie qui
traite un sujet compliqué celui de
l'avortement il raconte l'histoire d'une
jeune fille qui tombe enceinte à 16 ans
on regarde le clip
elle attend un
enfant elle voit les choses autrement
elle dit qu'elle se sent prête pour
qu'on l'appelle maman celui-ci c'est
pour toutes les
[Musique]
vie mère à tout prix
oh le titre là Aurélie on l'avait
partout ça a été un succès phénoménal
aussi mais ça vous a causé pas mal de
soucis quand même en fait ce qui s'est
passé c'est que mes deux premiers
morceaux qui ont fonctionné c'était des
chansons d'amour et je voulais montrer
que j'étais aussi capable de traiter de
certains sujets un petit peu plus
sensibles et d'accord mais tu vois ça a
été mal interprété tu te rappelles c'est
libération il y avait dit que c'était un
véritable histoire contre l'avortement
bah oui bah en fait le truc c'est que
moi j'écris mes propres textes je suis
auteur et je m'inspire vraiment de la
vie de tous les jours et moi je me
rappelle qu'à l'époque dans mon lycée il
y en avait deux ou trois des Aurélie et
ça m'avait marqué donc j'avais commencé
à écrire et puis quelques années plus
tard quand je préparais mon premier
album je me suis dit que ce serait
peut-être bien de d'en faire une chanson
quoi donc je regrette pas puisque
aujourd'hui c'est l'une des chansons
qu'on me demande le plus
jeune fille qui veut qui est enceinte et
qui veut garder son enfant
en tant que Provis pour voilà les mères
à tout prix et pour toutes celles qui
veulent donner la vie c'est pour ça que
ça a été délicat en fait
c'est toujours un sujet sensible et
toujours de nos jours il y a pas de
problème c'est pas c'est mieux que ça le
monde précise dans son article que vous
êtes défendu d'être anti-avortement mais
il souligne que le clip a cependant été
récupéré par des organisations proies et
opposées à la contraception et selon LCI
vous êtes considéré comme un modèle une
icône pour tous les militants
anti-avortement qu'est-ce que tu penses
de cette position écoute moi je fais la
musique avec le coeur comme je l'ai dit
tu as compris la polémique ou pas de ce
qui m'inspire la polémique après que ce
soit récupéré bien sûr on est dans un
monde aujourd'hui avec les réseaux
sociaux notamment tout est récupéré donc
je m'attendais aussi à ça et puis
c'était aussi une façon de
de parler de certains sujets parce que
je pense aujourd'hui que c'est aussi le
rôle d'un artiste de pouvoir mettre
certains sujets sur la table et si j'ai
pu aider à ce que le la rôle d'un
artiste la parole se libère autour de ce
sujet je pense que c'est ça peut être
bien le droit de penser ce qu'il veut
alors toi Patrick ne t'énerve pas je
vais parler d'argent
il m'a donné je t'aime très bien
mais je vais la poser quand même désolé
allez d'abord tu veux tu veux en premier
tu veux quoi Madonna ou l'argent allez
l'argent alors l'argent quand tout le
monde dit que tu touches une fortune
j'ai des chiffres j'ose même pas le dire
enfin je sais pas si tant mieux pour lui
oui
25 millions de dollars plus de 20
millions d'euros et à chaque fois
qu'elle passe à la radio puis empêche
combien
1500 euros par jour à peu près alors
il faut il faut quand même donner une
explication à ça parce que les chiffres
sont exacts effectivement
et 1500 par jour en fait alors je veux
bien en reparler encore une fois oui ça
me fait plaisir ça me fait plaisir en
plus j'ai des frères en ce moment donc
ça me fait très plaisir avant si tu veux
je suis auteur compositeur interprète
éditeur et producteurs c'est pour ça
bravo bravo bravo mais oui
c'est pour ça c'est pour ça qu'il touche
autant alors en fait c'est en plus ce
sont des chiffres bruts mais j'ai toutes
les casquettes sur cette chanson là et
donc sur une chanson qui est planétaire
qu'est-ce que tu veux ça rapporte un
petit peu de sous quand même forcément
quoi
tout va bien et donc et bien évidemment
il te reste pas ça dans ta poche à la
fin de à la fin de chaque jour à la fin
de chaque mois mais
en fait c'est pour montrer effectivement
qu'une chanson de 7 à Kaby et d'un
rapport absolument incroyable et c'est
ce qui fait la spécificité de cette
chanson qui est qui est un cas d'école
quoi
jouer au Mexique au Pérou en Allemagne
en Suède mais j'aime bien quand dans la
presse l'argent
ne m'intéresse pas tu dis là l'argent ne
m'intéresse pas
en fait l'argent m'intéresse pas du tout
à partir du moment où l'argent permet de
faire ce que tu as envie de faire au
moment où tu as envie de le faire mais
moi je suis pas pour ramasser les trucs
non plus et c'est simplement parce que
cette chanson a eu le bonheur et le
compositeur l'auteur le producteur a eu
le bonheur de de créer ce site espèce de
monstre comme ça que voilà c'est c'est
la vie qui m'a apporté ça et je crache
pas dessus et honnêtement je suis très
heureux encore aujourd'hui une
interpréter cette chanson de véhiculer
ce message que la message très très
positif et je suis absolument pas
frustré pour le raison et nous non plus
on est ravis toujours de l'entendre il
est à l'affiche du nouveau show stars 80
encore un voilà actuellement en tournée
à l'accord Arena de Paris le 17 décembre
c'est génial je sais que c'est une fête
d'enfer regardez
[Applaudissements]
ça continue encore et encore c'est que
le début d'accord d'accord
quelque chose devient le temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de l'espace
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chaque personne tellement que des dates
ont été rajoutés dans plusieurs ennemis
était Arena encore qui son avril le 2024
les amis il y a de nombreuses stars avec
toi on va les citer c'est des copains
Émile et images Sabrina Jean-Pierre
Mader William de début de soirée enfin
voilà et puis il y aura également des
dates Festival d'été dis-moi avec ce
petit peu d'argent que tu as gagné
quelle était ta plus grande folie
Patrick tu as eu un truc crazy
un truc un jour
j'avais vraiment un rendez-vous très
important ça fait très snob de raconter
ça à Los Angeles et en fait j'ai donc dû
prendre pour faire le rendez-vous j'ai
dû prendre le Concorde pour aller à New
York ensuite prendre une correspondante
pour arriver à Los Angeles et faire
l'inverse le lendemain matin et donc
c'était juste pour prendre un apéro avec
les Scotti Brothers et
et donc j'ai fait l'apéro avec eux je
suis rentré
je te l'apéro à Los Angeles
deux fois c'est que c'était pas cher
Colonel Reyel avec tes chansons et tout
cela maintenant tu vises
et ta mère
vous avez réagi quand il était
interprète plus producteur plus machin
et tout compositeur mais je suis je suis
producteur que depuis peu donc les
petites qui ont marché à l'époque
c'était pas encore producteur
je salue la performance extraordinaire
c'est gentil et toi aussi tu es en
tournée tu continues à toujours à
chanter tes chansons exactement donc cet
été il y a la tournée de la kermesse qui
aura lieu notamment à Nice début juillet
oui c'est ça pas mal de 5 6 7 juillet
exactement avec pas mal des artistes
2000 ensuite la Seyne-sur-Mer des années
80 on regarde des années 80 vraiment
alors toi justement quel regard tu vas
sur ces années 80 un énorme respect quoi
un énorme respect de se dire que des
décennies après le public est encore au
rendez-vous il continue à chanter à se
déplacer c'est inspirant tous les jeunes
qui arrivent aujourd'hui effectivement
et tant que tant que quelqu'un de très
malin n'aura pas créé un phénomène de
le fait en fait nous sommes le dernier
phénomène pratiquement pour faire la
fête c'est-à-dire on nous entendons les
baptêmes dans les mariages c'est vrai
que dans les enterrements d'ailleurs
oui parce qu'il y a la vie éternelle
derrière donc be alive pour la vie
éternelle aussi donc si j'ai appelé il y
a pas il y a pas très longtemps
et donc il faudra un jour que un jeune
par exemple crée un phénomène de fête
qui va qui va surpasser ce phénomène de
fait que nous avons nous créé et qui
reste encore très actuel aujourd'hui
Bernard en tout cas on souhaite vraiment
à tous les jeunes
laisse-moi tranquille un
jeune en tout cas merci de nous
transmettre toutes ces chansons on les a
encore dans la tête ça me fait toujours
plaisir de vous voir